this you have to see
Elise stefanic Republican congresswoman
from New York
explains how what Mike Pence did was
fine
and Trump was treated unfairly for the
documents document stuff
but Joe Biden is a national security
threat that's the that's the real issue
here there are three stories here two of
them the Republican ones are not a
concern but the Biden one that is the
real issue let's take a look at this and
she starts talking about a weaponized
FBI and
folks we have three situations we can
analyze them pretty clearly and this is
not the way that the line is that the uh
the the uh what would
I'm I'm searching for a metaphor here
let's just listen
Joe Biden uh he has had classified
documents going back to his time in the
Senate where he started serving before I
was born so this is a long-standing
national security threat setting aside
the very important fact that Hunter
Biden also had access and used as his
home address where those classified
documents were improperly and illegally
stored does she realize the number of
people that have access at Mar-A-Lago
like if she's concerned that Hunter
Biden sometimes went to his dad's house
she is going to be stunned to learn what
happens at Mar-A-Lago with regard to who
could have have that have had access to
the boxes of documents that Trump
directed to have placed down there we
don't even have evidence Biden knew he
had this stuff we don't have evidence
Pence knew he had the stuff let's
continue
this will be a part of the oversight
agenda and on the house intelligence
committee we absolutely want to make
sure we have all of the facts
[Music]
that
well let's highlight the difference here
in what the consequences have been you
had the FBI raid Mar-A-Lago you did not
see any of that happen for President Joe
Biden you know why
you know why there was a different
handling because the legal uh law
enforcement authorities trying to get
the Trump documents back spent months
trying to get them back through other
means with Biden and with pence in
Pence's defense Pence did the same thing
there would be no opportunity for a raid
or search warrant to be executed because
the amount of time between when the
documents were found and turned over was
so small that's why they're among many
other reasons by the way
what also is different is President
Trump as president has the right to
declassify documents that that's a ruse
okay he has the right to he didn't and
legal experts are almost unanimous on
the fact that just saying pack up my
documents and send them to my house does
not de facto declassify them just
because the president doesn't
so for a sitting president
what a rhetorical pretzel that Elise
stefanic has wedged herself into it may
not Shock you that Elise stefanic was a
gleeful endorser of George Anthony
kitara De volder Santos you know who I'm
talking about right the guy who invented
the heart transplant technique and built
the Eiffel Tower that George Santos
anyway she was lovingly gleefully and in
Dorsey an endorser rather
um of Santos shouldn't come as a huge
shock at some point I actually do think
that this will maybe not backfire on
Republicans but just fall flat and what
I mean by that is if you look at polling
and approval polling so far Joe Biden
has been unaffected by the classified
document situation my guess as to why is
that the American people realize there
is no evidence of any kind of malicious
intent or subterfuge whereas the Trump
situation is dramatically different and
Trump's approval continues to suffer I
think the American people are actually
smart enough to know and that's a phrase
that's often used by by Republicans to
say I believe the American people are
smart enough to realize what's be you
know when socialism it just really
genuinely seems as though people realize
the difference between the Trump
document story and the Pence Biden
stories which right now look relatively
similar although differences may come up
in the future let me know your thoughts
is it clear to you
that we are dealing with dramatically
different situations here in terms of
trump Biden and Pence with these
documents or do you think that it's
basically all the same thing let me know
make sure you're subscribed on YouTube
at youtube.com slash the David Pacman
show and make sure you're following me
on Twitter at dpacman are you tired of
the same old off-the-shelf grocery store
honey look no further than manukora our
sponsor the honey is made by bees that
pollinate the native Manuka trees in the
remote forests of New Zealand it gives
it a unique dark Rich delicious flavor
that you won't find in any other honey
it is 100 raw if you look at it side by
side with regular boring honey you can
see the difference I've got my Honeys
next to each other on the counter and it
looks very different manukura is also
responsible and sustainable all manukora
honey is harvested using traditional
methods so you can enjoy your creamy
caramel honey knowing that the
production was easy on the bees and on
the planet it's a perfect natural
sweetener I've been adding it to my tea
and my toast but because of the amazing
complex flavor I find myself using it in
things I didn't even put honey in before
like oatmeal and yogurt and smoothies I
have to admit my girlfriend once caught
me tasting Manuka Honey right off the
spoon because it's that good it really
stands out from everyday honey so don't
settle for the ordinary honey when you
can enjoy the unique delicious flavor of
manukura go to manukora.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman for a free pack of
honey sticks very nostalgic to when I
was a kid with your order a 15 value
tastes the difference for yourself the
link is down below